hello it's John Johnny okay ladies and
gentlemen we're getting exactly what we
wanted a Last of Us TV show from the
screenwriter of the hangover 3 and
Kristy Ellie oh my god it looks so much
like Kristy yeah I'm so excited for this
The Last of Us is one of the very few
video games I've actually beat in the
last few years so I want to talk about
why I think this is a great idea I want
to talk about some dream casting and you
best believe that when this show comes
out we'll be doing TV show reactions for
its which guys go check out our patreon
page over there we do TV show reaction
watch along so you sync up with the
timecode but we also have the option for
reaction highlights included and we edit
ourselves and those shows are
supernatural just started Doctor Who
attack on Titan death note my hero
academia and the two heroes movie we
will be covering heroes rising when that
is apt on screaming Code Geass hunter
hunter one punch man Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood and then there are
shows where we have just watch along for
them and those are agents of shield
Gotham Cobra Kai season 2 stranger
things season 3 Game of Thrones final
season black mirror season 5 haunting a
hill house and the Mandalorian and we've
organized all the links so that way it's
much easier for you to navigate it over
there so go check out our patreon page
we'll probably do YouTube cuts though
for Last of Us on the channel itself
anywho let's talk about this so for
video games like The Last of Us which
are so intricate in detail of its
storytelling and character development
most of the time when you do a movie
when you're trying to adapt a property
like this and same thing happens with
books a lot of the time you end up
having a sacrifice a hell of a lot
because you're trying to juggle one too
many things you're trying to have an
efficient enough story to tell in like
two hours but then you're also trying to
get like cool action sequences but you
also want to emulate the video game
style it's just way too much and
especially because there's no way you
can beat a video game like The Last of
Us in two hours so what you get is this
condensed piece so I've been saying for
the longest time that the best way to
adapt most of these video games unless
it's a fighting game like Mortal Kombat
like the upcoming Mortal Kombat movie
I'm looking forward to while those
characters have a history and while
there's so much story there video game
my Mortal Kombat you can just hop in and
play
you know it's one of those where is a
game like The Last of Us there's so much
exploration to be done you have to get a
condensed movie or you can do something
where you are adapting the video game
but you can even do an expansion of it
here like really explore a lot so I'm
excited that they do have Neil druckmann
the writer of The Last of Us involved in
here Craig Maas in man xenon eyes
amazing oh that's how you say it I think
maybe I don't know it just sounds like
amazing amazing well he has an amazing
work with Chernobyl apparently I haven't
seen it it's pretty great yeah yeah that
guy really does have some psycho boy
hate work the top Phillips and he does
have like a Todd Phillips esque career
in a way oh he's done a bunch of Parrott
he wrote and directed superhero movie
yeah and then he also like worked on the
scary movie films hangover 3 an identity
thief our favorite comedy and now he has
like this prestigious man which
Chernobyl yeah put something so deep
bleak thoughtful talk folks dead from
like his comedy is hopping over to Joker
so it is kind of funny that they work
together and now they're like tours then
pairing up and with his work that he did
entre noble I do see him being a perfect
match for something like this The
Witcher came out on Netflix and while
that is a book series first and then was
a video game we all know a lot of people
who haven't read the books but played
the video games went over to watch The
Witcher because they were big video game
fans while the critics didn't love the
show that much audiences really do dig
that series a lot the best way to adapt
especially a video game like The Last of
Us explore this world I think especially
for HBO would be perfect their work on
Watchmen was impeccable I love that
series my favorite show last year I semi
regret not reacting to it it kind of
like having that show for myself but
this one definitely will be reacting
John thoughts I just borrowed your copy
of The Last of Us and I'm excited to
play it from what I know about it from
having seen several cinematics and
knowing the gist of the game
my main concern about this news was just
that okay you know like the Walking Dead
has been such this juggernaut in this
kind of omniscient presence in the
zombie sphere that I was mainly worried
about an adaptation turning into
something like that but I think the
caliber of what HBO does and the thought
fulness that they seem to want to imbue
their projects with and Craig Mazin like
you know Chernobyl is a very thoughtful
show like we said from what I've been
able to glean of the tone even Neil
druckmann was saying he wanted the game
this sort of dynamic between Jill and
Ellie to be a mishmash of like the world
of a George Romero zombie movie with
like Hartigan from Sin City looking
after Nancy so I feel like if you can
really get those tones and I know in the
last of us you're traveling through a
lot of different areas it's sort of like
a road kind of a thing that seems really
exciting to me and I feel like that
could at least explore some things that
other things haven't perhaps you know I
think there's still plenty of things
that separate the last of us from
something like a typical zombie
apocalypse because from the very
beginning when you're in the apocalypse
world it's the humans who are really
scary beyond the infected characters you
still do get a bunch of weird-ass
creatures in there like that clickers
the stalkers the bloaters which is
something shows like The Walking Dead
don't have evolution of the virus where
they do morph and I'm really hoping
they're probably gonna go for visual
effects CGI but a part of me is hoping
that they do really great blend with
practical effects for those kind of
creatures on this series yeah from from
what I've seen of all the designs and
stuff it seems like they have a really
good opportunity to do a bit of both and
yeah like especially having the Resident
Evil movies be a letdown if you're a fan
of the game I do really love the
potential of getting those like more
sci-fi evolutions on the mutation and
whatever that is yet and as opposed to
something like The Walking Dead which is
kind of just like stay alive survive
there's an actual goal here Ellie is a
character who could possibly be the cure
to the virus that gives you like an
actual hope in the series as opposed to
just stay alive that's how do we live
amongst this there's a goal here and
then you also got a tale of Joel who's
grieving from the loss of his family so
you got this interesting like emotional
repressed father-daughter dynamic
between Joel and Ellie and it is these
two central characters who interact with
other people but like I said a big part
of them what makes it different there's
a hopeful end game to it so with that in
mind I mean for dream casting there's
someone I've always thought would be a
absolute perfect fit for Joel and then
there's someone I have in mind who I
don't think is
the obvious pick for someone like Elly
but my Joel pick would have to be Logan
Marshall Greene yes he looks like Tom
Hardy but he's not just discounts on
party all right I kind of if you see his
work in the invitation which is this man
who's grieving over the loss of a child
then you got his action work in the film
like upgrade I think you kind of combine
both of those elements from what he
provided with the invitation and what he
provided with upgrade you can have an
absolutely stellar Joel performance with
Logan Marshall Greene my kind of odd
pick because I feel like someone might
resort and that yeah she looks like
Ellen Page but she's a little too old
now some people might vote for like a
Sophia Willis you know that's just kind
of the impression I can stay away from
all those like hate girls right yeah
because I feel like yeah you don't want
someone too distracting in that room my
pick would actually be Elsie Fisher from
oh yeah I wrote her down oh you did yeah
that was my first time and if you've
seen her work in eighth grade this this
woman who's having to overcome all these
insecurities learn to be confident I
think she can bring that level of
vulnerability but also demonstrate a
different side of her which is truly a
survivor and someone still having to
learn to develop her own strength as the
series progresses it's a show and it's
might be a situation that ends up like a
watchman limited series when it was a
really pitch as a series or they were
like oh he doesn't want to return it's
just a limited series this could be that
case but if they want to make seasons
out of this I think you do need someone
who is young who will age in a way that
isn't like Chandler Riggs from the walk
yeah second pick to play those late
seasons of the long hair yeah well
there's only one Joel pick for me and
that's Gerard Butler because we all
wanted that movie this might not be like
dead on the nose but I thought Michael
Wiesman could do it the guy who's the
oldest brother in Hill House he was
Daario naharis and Game of Thrones oh
yeah yeah especially with a beard you
know he's got that kind of general look
anyway you could maybe use somebody like
Sadie sink from stranger things who's
the sister of the Decker Montgomery
character or Millie ship hero from
hereditary because she's growing up a
little more you know she's like early
teenager now and you know she doesn't
look as a shovel tips and she doesn't
hereditary in real life so I thought
that could maybe be just kind of an
interesting
left field casting choice aside from
various other jokes like Liam Hemsworth
Kaylee's finding from Pacific Rim
uprising I thought might maybe could fit
that or a Katelyn Deaver from book smart
but you know those were my just kind of
off the dome I think whoever they get
will pavia a good pic because knowing
that I hope that with the fan casting
this is more of a Jon Bernthal and
Punisher situation where when the
casting is there you go yes that works
and not know not module that my like and
even if it is like oh didn't expect that
I have enough faith in the people who
are helping this that they're gonna
choose the right person for the job even
McGregor yes but yeah I think they
should do this with other video game
adaptations to Metal Gear Solid I know
Jordan buck Roberts has been aiming to
get his movie off the ground for years I
do not see a way Metal Gear Solid could
possibly work as a movie I think TV is
the best way to do it
get free Bergen Seltzer oh yeah with the
evolution of television yeah this is the
perfect fit they don't want to make a
Last of Us movie Last of Us already like
a really long movie already so the way
you can honor it and do something more
with it this is the way to do it I'm so
excited for it what do you think about
the last of us who do you think should
be the stars of this show
what other video games do you want to
see adapted into a television show leave
your thoughts down below subscribe to
the reel rejects click that notification
Bell check us out on patreon last but
not least let's end this with a Tyler
Haig hey buddy I promise you you get one
this month his name is Tyler he's quite
the smiler simple styler I'll let him
ride me like a miler his name means lair
and he's quite the player an American
taxpayer who can probably land a date
with Buffy the Vampire Slayer for the
man from Wisconsin has an enormous
Johnson mister hey can sometimes be
vague um forgive you if you mistake Greg
for Craig you're always welcome through
my door for you bought me a Playstation
4 now I can play The Last of Us 2 for
our love is true we're conjoined at the
heart like superglue I'll never be
through with you pull me out of a funk
when I was feeling blue and if you asked
for the ps4 back
I'll freakin sue you don't do it Tyler
don't do it I know what you're up to